hello america matthew mcconaughey here
coming to you from austin texas
movie theaters they employ over 150
000 americans they are the unsung heroes
who help bring movie magic to the big
screen
obviously it's been a very hard year for
them furloughs
closures basically the longest
intermission that they could have ever
imagined
thanks to their dedication and
resilience theaters are coming back
and now i'd like to introduce to you a
few people who are working tirelessly
to help bring big screen entertainment
back into your
lives so take a seat show's about the
game
come on
guys we're on right now
i've been working here for 30 years 12
years 15 years
tell me you're not thinking what i think
you're thinking hold on
i've been a runner bartender a server
and a supervisor
you feel part of something bigger we met
working here
and now we're married there's nothing
better than theater popcorn
the movie theater is a treasure i want
to trade for anything welcome back to
the cinemas
we've been waiting for you
the movies the way you've always loved
them
is the way to see them again the future
i can see it time to get back to work
you in i'm ready if you are let's go
hold on everybody wow
giddy up the big screen is back